several reported cases of death
following a cleanse
what about pooping that may happen what
last time i did i was puking engineering
[Music]
is there something you've been trying to
change about yourself for years
for some of us it's overcoming crippling
social anxiety
for others it's a serious health issue
that they cannot find the answer to and
even though you've consumed countless
books
podcasts videos seminars tactics
strategies and methods to fix it
you're still doing it hey i'm leon
over the past few years i've achieved
every goal i've set for myself building
a business moving to australia selling
my business traveling europe getting a
us visa starting a new business in the
us
yet something was always missing i was
quite miserable there was always this
underlying feeling that
i have to achieve the next thing first
in order to finally enjoy my life and be
fulfilled and even though i had
everything i dreamed of i was restless
anxious and stressed i wanted to achieve
more to live without regrets
but when i look back at those years i
regret them i wouldn't want to relive
any of it
i realized that if i keep living like
this will i just regret
all of it then what's the point of doing
anything
then what's the point of living i spent
close to 50 000
on self-help seminars coaching and
programs and i had already been
practicing the tried and proven methods
for years
meditation visualization incantation
exercising gratitude journals
and a bunch of other weird stuff
[Music]
but no matter what i tried i would
always get sucked back into the devil
cycle of
negativity beating myself up and not
doing enough
you will never be enough what if all
these things were just
like a band-aid or a broken leg this
year i decided
to try a few things that i had never
tried before
things that might help me get to the
root of the problem
things that uh well
i can't do this man let's just say out
of the ordinary
in this journey i learned something i
wish i would have learned years ago
to start off i wanted to do something
extreme that defeats stress and anxiety
like nothing else
okay maybe not that extreme so we bought
a freezer filled it with water and
cooled it down to a freezing temperature
and there we had our own ice bath
proven to not just be excellent for
recovery but also to reset your nervous
system
whatever that means and drastically
lower stress anxiety
and depression my buddy aaron had
already been taking ice baths daily and
it's been working really well for him
we'll put over some epic music that'll
make you look like a hero
going in here
[Music]
he didn't actually fight i just added
that i wanted to commit to 14 days
taking two ice baths a day first thing
in the morning and one in the evening
for two minutes each to fully commit
i told my buddy aaron that if i'm not in
the ice bath within five minutes of
waking up i give him a thousand bucks
i know that tomorrow it'll be easy i
will jump out of bed
in no time i will feel empowered and
fresh
and excited to jump into that cold
plunge
it'll be a piece of cake look at him
sitting there
quick what's the time
[Music]
so yeah i shouldn't really worry much
longer
[Music]
easy
so we agreed to extend the time i have
to get into the ice baths to 15 minutes
and i got sick for two days immediately
after so i decided to work my way up
starting with just one 60 second ice
bath a day while also
increasing the duration
[Music]
one thing is for sure you take an ice
bath you're pretty much guaranteed to
feel great
but is this really a long-term solution
[Applause]
i wanted to go deeper i wanted to know
what is causing the stress in the first
place
oftentimes it's something in our past
certain beliefs that we formed about
ourselves and the world that might have
served us then to cope as a child but
are limiting us today as an adult
and to uncover these things i wanted to
use a proven tool that has already
helped me immensely in achieving goals
and business
journaling but not just for a couple of
hours i wanted no distractions be
somewhere in nature and reflect for an
entire weekend on my past so me and
aaron decided to take a trip into the
wilderness and go separate ways to spend
48 hours in complete isolation with
nothing but a tent
food and our journals hey man i was
thinking maybe we should just get the
world's best pencil
it says sketch or some kind of street
it's kind of sketchy
we are currently discussing journaling
techniques that we can go through and
aaron suggested something really good
make a list of all your emotional events
whether it's like big traumas little
trauma you start at the beginning
kind of step into it a little bit so you
can kind of relive it and then step out
of it from
there what you want to do is you want to
figure out okay what do i need to learn
from this
so you're changing the meaning until you
come to a place where there's some inner
peace
we'll see if we're not messed up anymore
we finally fix our issues because we are
deeply broke we're going to face our
demons that's really what it is
and if we find out that we couldn't
solve our issues then that means we're
fundamentally broken
damn so much
we're not just carrying the equipment
we're carrying
a completely different type of baggage
as well
went the wrong way because we went the
wrong way like we have to go back all
the way again
yeah sorry that's the right one now man
we've been walking for
how long a couple hours we kept going
there was a swamp
so many mosquitoes we had to go back
again so i'm just gonna keep
going that way now and hopefully find a
spot somewhere i guess i'll see you
again in two days
all right looks like i found my spot i'm
so exhausted i'm sweating everywhere i'm
very very dirty set up my tent set up
everything and then
start journaling all right 48 hours
isolation and journaling let's do this
let's see what i think i might be able
to dig up there's definitely a lot
around family stuff
about a year ago something happened i
basically had an anxiety attack
socially that messed me up like i've
been dealing with a ton of social
anxiety
i was pretty messed up back then in
terms of feeling like an outsider being
very
pessimistic and also
[Applause]
kind of like hating people and hating
myself i feel like
you know those people that like you know
they get paralyzed and they have to
learn how to walk
all over again i think there's a lot of
unresolved anger within me
yeah and i guess that's why i always
feel like i need to do something i
always need to
do more because i feel like there's
something i
need to overcompensate for
maybe up to this point i've probably
spent about 30
000 in different coaches psychologists
therapists
different uh trainings and stuff just to
get over this yeah psychologists emdr
therapy
just different like identities identity
work attention ayahuasca talked to some
shamans done some combo
we go through life and uh the teacher
yells at us or something we use our hand
we answer
the question but we're wrong and all the
kids laugh at us right and then all of a
sudden that creates this story of like
oh hey i'm not smart or
the kids don't like me or whatever we
hit seven and like you know maybe this
girl rejects us or something and then we
hit
like 10 and maybe we get bullied or
whatever all these different events
that we don't know how to process as
we're going through life but they they
leave
imprints in our like unconscious just
looking through the
events in my life that came up there's a
pattern there
really gotten much deeper into some of
the issues that i've been facing yeah
just looking at it from a third person's
perspective again and
looking at what are my assumptions what
meaning did i attach to it i have such a
clear picture now of what has been
happening all these years
and i wish i would have taken the time
to look into this
deeper earlier because it would have
saved me so much frustration
it's so interesting what you come up
with and then how you feel about it
this ended up being one of the most
eye-opening weekends of my life
but it definitely would have been much
better if there wouldn't have been so
many nice snake right there
based on the fact that it's not running
away i'm going to say it's poisonous
[Music]
i've been stung i don't know how many
times and camping by ourselves at night
added to the experience of facing out
demons
after all this forest inhabits venomous
snakes alligators
coyotes and feral hogs okay the sun has
set
and i'm all by myself with snakes hogs
coyotes either way
i've got my knife ready to defend myself
and again i've heard something in the
woods
[Music]
tonight so i have to get out anyways
and after 48 hours of isolation we
returned home
and there he is are you still messed up
or you think you're fixed now
hopefully there's more mature versions
of ourselves yeah i want to shower so
bad yeah
i want you to shout out so bad you
probably have similar
thought which is why didn't i do that
earlier
you mean this why did that do this work
i could have saved myself so much pain
i've never learned so much about myself
in such a short period of time and going
into detail would be too much for this
video but while shining a light on these
issues you're facing to understand where
they come from is a huge step
is that enough to actually resolve these
issues just because the analytical mind
finally understands what's going on in
the subconscious mind that doesn't mean
the subconscious mind understands it too
it's still running the show
it's said that our subconscious controls
95 of everything we do
so why not go straight to the root
alright so i just had a chat with
the hypnosis and nlp coach basically
she's going to get me into
a hypnotic state where i can access my
subconscious find the program that is
simply not working that is misguiding me
that is
holding me back and then reprogramming
that after filling out a survey we had a
look at my current stress levels
emotional stress is the one that you
actually go into the high category
your well-being score is a little low i
told her about the things i had
discovered through journaling and
looking into my past
that is a subconscious program that's
running in the background
and so as hard as you can try that is
going to
influence and color your efforts and
with that we went into the hypnosis
let's go ahead and take a couple of deep
breaths in
good and if you were to know how old
were you
ask your unconscious mind what it can
learn from this event i was in that
meditative hypnotic state for 55 minutes
and it really felt like 20 minutes
and in the process she was guiding me
through the so-called timeline therapy
basically going back to the earliest
memory where
that belief came from that ended up
creating so much stress for myself and
taking out all the learnings as well as
giving
reassurance to that inner child that
uh needed exactly that gratitude is one
of those
elevated emotions that helps us actually
build the capacity in our battery
and so when we feel gratitude we know
that
from research that that changes our
physiological state like i know about it
okay but i just haven't been practicing
it consistently because i always thought
you know what i'll just achieve things
first and then
after that i'll figure out the whole
happiness thing but for some reason it
was hard to get to a state of feeling
grateful
instead i would start feeling anxious
restless short of breath while i did
practice it
my restless nature might be no surprise
considering what we found when i got my
brain scanned by my buddy chris
whoa this is a tony robbins scary
v-brain
oh no but maybe i was doing it wrong or
was something else getting in the way
the way emotions work as emotions are
stored in your body so what if i might
have resolved a trauma consciously and
even subconsciously
but my body still had the emotions
stored in it and continue to run the old
pattern and how would i go about
releasing emotions that are trapped
inside the body
and when i met you he was having these
wounds
around his ears they take poison from a
frog
but i would never be that stupid right
introducing combo combo is a south
american ritual also referred to as the
warriors initiation that uses the poison
of the giant monkey frog from the amazon
they burn you and then they put the
venom on the burn so it enters your
system
and for 30 minutes your body goes then
you feel like you're dying
while none of it has been scientifically
proven people who have used it swear by
it because it's said to purify the body
and help with numerous conditions like
depression anxiety or stress by
releasing bad energies and trapped
emotions from the body
at the very least i would probably
strengthen my immune system so i thought
why not aaron has done it multiple times
what could possibly go wrong
what should i expect combo is a poison
for this reason it could cause vomiting
sweating and a rapid heart rate i know
there
have been several reported cases of
death
following a cleanse with combo it's a
series of uncomfortable
events the first uncomfortable event is
is the burning
and she's also going to offer you some
uh some samanga it's another indigenous
medicine that they put in your eye and
it feels like you just got pepper
sprayed okay i just did the
huge mistake of actually asking dr
google
oh man no comfortable
three is the water portion you have to
drink i think it's an entire gallon of
water
i have to drink 3.7 liters in 15 minutes
because you're going to be puking
you're it's a purging medicine pooping
that's that
that may happen or maybe not what that
may happen
i might myself last time i did it i was
puking at the same time
and then the fourth come from
uncomfortable event what is the combo
luckily the first dose you get is a
smaller one of just
three dots i mean you're only doing
three dots so like um then again i just
see a woman faint off three dots
aaron can't you tell me this after the
session a case study from 2017 describes
a 42 year old woman who died after
taking part in a cleanse
why did i look this up i always make the
same mistake i just can't resist
you know i was kind of uh optimistic
before like you know aaron has done it
but now i feel a little bit terrified
you know i like being
aware of potential symptoms um and one
symptom or potential risk i don't like
is uh death
that's one of the symptoms that i try to
stay away from because i heard it's
unhealthy it's too late now i'm doing
this i'm committed combo is legal
and we have done it with a certified
practitioner make sure you do not
do anything in this video without an
expert or just just don't do it
just do not do any of it the ceremony
starts
soon i've just gotten a message from her
it's going to be a beautiful afternoon
of healing i can't wait to see you soon
frog smiley all right
all right we made it to the place we got
the buckets
for purging a gallon of water and with
that
the ceremony started falling in the
highest vibrational frequencies of
love and light and pure source
[Music]
consciousness
all right so we will go ahead and um do
synenga eyedrops
oh no it's starting
[Music]
go ahead and open your eyes
and then it was time for the combo
[Music]
thank you
yeah it felt uh almost good in the
beginning because i felt the pulse
rising
well that's what it felt like that i
could just feel my heartbeat
throughout my whole body and then later
on it definitely got more challenging
so that was combo yeah i feel pretty
exhausted feel pretty drained
um calm as well i'm gonna take it easy
for the rest of the day
[Music]
all right it's been a few days yesterday
was one of the
shittiest days i've had in a long time
again felt like i should be further
ahead right now
i should be doing again putting too much
pressure on myself maybe this is just
i'm just
doomed to be wired that way but then i
remembered
where i was four years ago sleeping four
to five hours a night because
i was struggling with insomnia and i
would wake up with the racing heart in
the mornings
my doctor telling me that i had
developed light asthma because of stress
really bitter towards the world and
humanity as a whole and myself
looking back i was so much
worse at this in the past and it's been
taking me
years to improve a little bit where i
actually notice it after i actually look
for it
i've tried all these things over the
past few years
and i've worked so hard on myself and it
all has helped in some way
i can safely say i'm the happiest i've
ever been and it really
keeps moving up whenever you fall back
into one of your old patterns
whatever it may be for you then it can
often feel like you're not moving
forward and you're stuck
when you zoom out you may find that
you've actually come
a long way and maybe there isn't a big
fix that once you do that it's fixed but
maybe it's literally just
a long term journey that is supposed to
be like that so i'm keeping a gratitude
journal again which i stopped doing at
some point back in the day i don't know
why
a way more positive attitude just random
moments of joy
uh way more energy when it comes to
working i don't get drained as quickly i
sleep much better
and it's not this one quick fix where
you do it once in your complete 180 but
it's just
this thing that really helps and if you
just keep doing it it gets easier maybe
that's the purpose of life just overcome
challenges and that's one of them and
it's a lifelong commitment
to focus on what's beautiful in your
life to focus on what you can be
thankful for